es sind Demos das sind sprechöre es sind
Verhaftungen im Iran brodelt es
unverändert nach dem Tod einer
22-jährigen Frau reißen die Proteste im
Land nicht ab es ist der unermüdliche
Kampf gegen die strengen Sittengesetze
der Molas
es sind Bilder die um die Welt gehen
mutiger Iranerin reißen sich ihre
Kopftücher von den Haaren und verbrennen
sie auf offener Straße es sind mutige
Frauen die die strengen
frauenfeindlichen Sittengesetze der
Mullahs nicht mehr akzeptieren wollen
Auslöser der aktuellen Proteste der Tod
der 22 Jahre alten Mascha Amini sie wird
vor zwei Wochen von der iranischen
Sittenpolizei festgenommen und das nur
weil sie angeblich ihr Kopftuch nicht
richtig trägt
auf der Polizeistation fällt sie ins
Koma ausgelöst durch Schläge der Polizei
die Behörden weisen jedoch diese Version
zurück sprechen von Herzproblemen
drei Tage nach ihrer Verhaftung am 16
September stirbt Mascha Amini im
Krankenhaus an ihren Verletzungen
seither ist der Iran in Aufruhr
[Applaus]
mit brutaler Härte gehen die
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Freiheitskämpfer vor schlagen auf die
Demonstranten ein Schießen mit scharfer
Munition in die Menge verhaften tausende
und schalten das Internet ab
immer öfter bezahlen DemonstrantInnen
ihren Kampf für die Freiheit mit dem
Leben schon 50 Tote sind es seit dem
Beginn der Proteste weltweit
solidarisieren sich die Menschen mit dem
Aufstand im Iran fordern die Absetzung
des grausamen iranischen mullerregimes
und wollen konkrete Hilfeleistungen so
zum Beispiel Elon Musk der reichste
Mensch der Welt möchte sein Starling
Satellitensystem zur Verfügung stellen
heißt die Iraner bekommen wohl bald
Internet aus dem All ohne dass die
Mullahs es abschalten können ein
weiterer Hoffnungsschimmer für die
mutigen Frauen und Männer die im Iran
für ihre Freiheit auf die Straße gehen
und dabei alles riskieren
[Musik]